it felt like it was just yesterday in  her first movie I was 14 she's 21 I  missed you and Sam now and has a little  baby and he's running around the set and  my kids have grown up and they're on the  set we feel like a family I was very  excited to come back to get to be the  three amigos again know like we were  last time I love Maleficent she's just  very playful and a little crazy try it  with a little less fine hello  she's wild you have to do a sequel  because you believe you have another  chapter of the story and now we have  Aurora as a young woman and even  Maleficent has trouble dealing with that  yes no I wasn't really asking I love the  mother-daughter story and so Maleficent  see of all and Aurora have this slightly  dysfunctional family and they may be  messed up in many many ways but they  have a very honest relationship it's one  of the beautiful things that makes her  family she's asking you to trust me love  doesn't always end well beastie  you  [Music]